something we've been talking a lot about
here grocery prices they've been on the
rise during the pandemic and certainly
we know some of you have had a really
hard time making ends meet to help out
and give back to our community eight
news now has partnered with albertsons
and vaughn's to help gift you a good day
and i have the pleasure of gifting a
good day to one very lucky albertson's
customer she stole my heart here's a
look
i met jorgen at the albertsons on
charleston and rainbow she's fallen on
hard times the cost of groceries isn't
making things any easier we're talking
about grocery prices
tell me how are you feeling it because
everybody is somehow it's outrageous i'm
on social security this is like killing
me everything has gone up a dollar here
a dollar there 50 cents like it's
ridiculous she said between the cost of
food and the cost of gas she doesn't go
anywhere and eats as little as possible
in fact she even had to change what she
buys i only ate chicken breasts and i'm
eating chicken thighs a little bit
cheaper but you know you have to make do
with what you put what you get
indeed you do you kind of have to make
sacrifices in some way shape or form
well we want to make sure that you have
a better day
here at 8 news now and albertson's we'd
like to gift you a good day we'd like to
take care of your groceries today
i can't believe this
what do you think i thank you very much
i can't even tell you how happy i am
about this thank you all i really do
appreciate it it is taken care of and we
appreciate you we're so glad that we're
able to do this i know you're smiling
under that mask too i am
a smile and maybe a little tear too
jordan was just so wonderful i was so
glad to meet her
hey you never know you could be next be
sure to watch good day las vegas for
another surprise we have that tomorrow